在上一个视频中，你看到了如何
在有正确答案的情况下
评估 LLM 的输出。
因此我们可以
编写一个函数，
明确地告诉我们
LLM 是否
输出了正确的类别
和产品列表。
但如果 LLM 被用于生成文本，
而且没有
唯一正确的文本呢？
让我们来看看
如何评估这类
LLM 输出的方法。
这是我常用的辅助函数，
给定一个顾客消息："告诉我
关于 SmartX Pro 手机
和 FotoSnap 相机的信息。"
这里有几个工具函数
可以获取助手的回答。
这基本上是
Isa 在之前视频中
演示过的流程。
助手的回答是："当然，我很乐意帮忙！"
关于 SmartX Pro 手机，
等等。
那么，你如何评估这是否
是一个好的回答呢？
看起来有很多可能的
好回答。
评估这个问题的一种方法
是编写一个评分标准，
即一套指导方针，
从不同维度
评估这个回答，
然后用它来
决定你是否对
这个回答满意。
让我演示如何做到这一点。
让我创建一个
小数据结构，
用于存储顾客消息
以及产品信息。
我将指定一个提示，
用所谓的
"评分标准"来评估
助手的回答。我稍后
会解释这是什么意思。
这个提示在系统消息中说：
"你是一个助手，
通过查看客服人员
用于生成回复的上下文，
来评估客服人员回答
用户问题的效果。"
这个回复是我们
在笔记本前面部分获得的，
即助手的回答。
我们将在这个提示中
指定数据：顾客消息是什么，
上下文是什么，
即提供了哪些产品和
类别信息，
以及 LLM 输出了什么。
然后，这是一个评分标准。
我们希望 LLM
"将提交答案的事实内容
与上下文进行比较。
忽略风格、语法
或标点符号的差异。
然后，
我们希望它检查几件事，
比如："助手的回复
是否仅基于
提供的上下文？
答案是否包含
上下文中未提供的信息？
回复与
上下文之间是否
存在分歧？"
这就是所谓的评分标准，
它指定了
我们认为答案应该
达到什么要求，
才算是一个好的答案。
最后，
我们希望它打印出是或否，
等等。
现在，
如果我们运行这个评估，
结果如下。
它说："助手的回复
仅基于
提供的上下文。"
在这种情况下，它似乎没有
捏造新信息。
没有分歧。
用户问了两个问题，
回答了问题一，
回答了问题二。
所以两个问题都回答了。
我们看这个输出，
也许会得出结论，
这是一个相当不错的回复。
需要注意的是，
这里我使用的是
ChatGPT 3.5 Turbo 模型
进行评估。
为了获得更严格的评估，
可能值得考虑
使用 GPT-4，因为即使你在生产环境中部署
3.5 Turbo 并生成
大量文本，如果你的评估
是一个
偶发性的操作，
那么为稍贵的
GPT-4 API 调用付费，
以获得更严格的输出评估，
可能是明智的。
我希望你能从
这里带走的
一个设计模式是：
当你可以指定一个评分标准时，
即一个
用于评估
LLM 输出的
标准列表，
那么你实际上可以
使用另一个 API 调用
来评估你的第一个 LLM 输出。
还有另一个设计模式，
对某些应用程序来说
可能很有用，
那就是如果你能
提供一个理想的回复。
这里，我将指定一个测试
样例，顾客消息是
"告诉我关于
SmartX Pro 手机的信息"，
等等。
这里有一个理想答案。
这是假设有一位专业的
人工客服代表
写了一个非常好的答案。
专家说，这将是一个很好的答案：
"当然！SmartX ProPhone 是一款……"
它继续提供
很多有用的信息。
现在，期望任何 LLM
逐字生成
这个确切的答案
是不合理的。
在经典的
自然语言处理
技术中，有一些
传统指标
用于衡量 LLM 输出是否
类似于
这些专家人工编写的输出。
例如，
有一个叫做 BLEU 分数的指标，
BLEU，你可以在网上搜索
了解更多。
它可以衡量
两段文本之间的相似程度。
但
实际上有一种更好的方法，
那就是
你可以使用一个提示（我将在这里指定），
让一个
LLM 来比较自动生成的
客服代理输出
与上面刚才看到的、
由人类撰写的
理想专家回复
之间的对应程度。
这是我们可以使用的提示，
即我们将使用一个 LLM，
告诉它作为一个助手，
通过将回复（即自动生成的回复）
与理想的（专家）
人工编写的
回复进行比较，
来评估
客服代理回答
用户问题的效果。
我们将提供数据：顾客的请求是什么，
专家编写的理想回复是什么，
然后我们的 LLM
实际输出了什么。
这个评分标准来自
OpenAI 开源的 evals 框架，
这是一个出色的框架，
包含了许多评估方法，
由 OpenAI 开发者
以及更广泛的
开源社区贡献。
事实上，如果你想，
你可以自己向
这个框架贡献一个评估方法，
帮助其他人评估他们的
大型语言模型输出。
在这个评分标准中，
我们让 LLM
"将提交答案的事实内容
与专家答案进行比较。
忽略风格、语法
或标点符号的任何差异。"
你可以随时暂停视频
并
仔细阅读这部分，
但关键是我们让它
进行比较，并输出从 A 到 E 的评分，
具体取决于
"提交的答案是否是专家
答案的子集且完全一致"，
还是"提交的答案是
专家答案的超集
且与之完全一致"。
后者可能意味着它产生了幻觉
或编造了一些
额外的事实。
"提交的答案包含
与专家答案
相同的所有细节"，
是否存在分歧，或者
"答案有所不同，但
这些差异
从事实角度来看
并不重要"。
LLM 将选择
看起来最合适的
描述。这是我们
刚才得到的助手回答，
我认为这是一个相当好的答案，
但现在让我们看看
当它将助手回答与
测试集的理想答案
进行比较时会怎样。
哦，看起来得了 A。
它认为
"提交的答案是
专家答案的子集，
并且与之
完全一致"，
这对我来说听起来是正确的。
这个助手回答比
顶部那个
长篇专家回答要短得多，
但希望是一致的。
同样，这个例子中我使用的是
GPT-3.5 Turbo，
但为了获得更严格的评估，
在你自己的应用程序中
使用 GPT-4 可能更有意义。
现在，让我们尝试
完全不同的东西。
我将提供一个非常
不同的助手回答："生活
就像一盒巧克力"，
引自电影《阿甘正传》。
如果我们对其进行评估，
它输出 D，并得出结论：
"提交的答案与
'生活就像一盒巧克力'
和专家答案之间存在分歧。"
所以它正确地判断这是
一个相当糟糕的回答。
就这样了。
我希望你能从
这个视频中带走两种设计模式。
第一，即使没有
专家提供的理想答案，
如果你能编写一个评分标准，
你可以用一个
LLM 来评估另一个 LLM 的输出。
第二，如果你能提供
专家给出的理想答案，
那可以帮助你的 LLM
更好地比较
特定的助手输出
是否与专家提供的
理想答案相似。
希望这能帮助你
评估你的 LLM 系统输出。
这样，无论是在开发过程中，
还是当
系统运行并获得回复时，
你都
可以继续监控其性能，
并拥有这些工具
来持续评估和
不断提高
系统的性能。